[Music]
forty-two seconds of Disney logos my
name's Ralph narration so the plot of
this videogame is that Ralph Fiennes
stumps to sleep in and a bulldozer comes
by they remove this one stump for some
stupid reason and then Ralph who
apparently has very specific sleeping
needs gets angry and destroys entire
apartment buildings but the coke
everybody was doing in the 80s this is
exactly what I used to yell at my
college girlfriend shortly before
ruining sex if he was a regular
contractor carpenter you would not be
able to fix the damage that I do as
quickly wreck-it Ralph would be amazing
at cinema since the movie speeds up time
during the sequence to show how much
everything's changed over the years but
hardly anything changes he'll a
realistic time lapse would be to show
this arcade going out of business for a
few years of becoming a Ruby Tuesday
it's certainly better than keeping all
these outdated games in the same spot
for 30 years without any turnover also
if you look closely the fix-it felix
game apparently only has one level
there's apparently nowhere to go after
this I see you got some Toy Story in my
wreckit-ralph once again there's
virtually no way these game characters
could do this on scene but hey I just
beliefs been drunk before so maybe I can
accept at the start since everybody in
the video game universe realizes this is
all a show why is Ralph ostracize what
this movie is saying is that our human
projection of Ralph's villainy
translates to the characters in the
video game world but meanwhile ruined
Ken can be battling and decide to get a
drink together after the arcade is
closed because they know it's all
make-believe
I am Zangief I'm bad guy is he though in
the original Street Fighter 2 zingy was
just another character you could play
just like guile or E Honda or Blanca it
was one of those boss characters that
you couldn't play until a champion
edition came out what makes an gif a
bigger bad guy than say Ken chun-li or
dhalsim dhalsim I am bad honestly when
and why did we convince ourselves that
addiction recovery just had to include
unison group chants so they were all in
the pac-man game for that bad anon
meeting but in just a few moments
everyone's gonna act like going into a
game not your own AKA game jumping is a
bad thing but clearly the act itself is
okay if the circumstances are right so
this video game subway travels through a
surge protector where all the videogame
characters can go back to their homes
but what happens if the game is plugged
in elsewhere surely not every game in
the arcade hooks up to this one surge
protector also even though that can't be
all the games in the arcade it's
too many plugs holy hell this is a fire
hazard if ever I saw one how is this
place not burned down already named Lera
Croft haha but how does ralph know about
Laura Croft a character who was never an
arcade fixture yeah bring any fruit with
you no no no fruit this works I like how
the creatures here run away from Ralph
because he's a bad guy but that t-rex
back there isn't scaring anyone he spent
so much time on Easter eggs you forgot
about consistency you don't regenerate I
have no doubt about this but it does
raise this question there are multiple
copies of these arcade games all around
the world right there are thousands of
other record roms pac-man's etc and did
they all go through existential crises
the nice landers know how to party they
even got Skrillex
but I'm still left wondering why are
there so many of them there are a finite
number of windows in the felix game and
way more citizens here at this party
than windows granted there's half a
boiled egg and a piece of bacon at the
Stan's so maybe we've got some cross
game celebrating going on here which I
would then sin for just being more game
jumping being casually overlooked by a
movie that screams about how bad game
jumping is you're just the bad guy who
wrecks the bill view again what are all
these people pissed about are they the
only video game characters who don't
know they're in a game do they really
live their lives inside this machine and
get upset when ralph comes in to wreck
their home do they not realize that it
all goes back to normal once the game is
over cuz with these assholes
oh come on this is the lost and found
inside the Tempur machine if you lose
your life outside of the game you don't
regenerate but apparently you can lose
your tempers place and just get it right
back the scene of eight quarters to play
doesn't exaggerate enough this is burnt
of arcades diet by the way it's made
your mama's Popeyes him lasting even
this long without being found out it's
kind of ridiculous yep there were two
big-budget movies in 2012 that made
weird Mother Hubbard references this and
the Amazing Spiderman how did that even
happen I guess this is her first time
playing this game good thing too because
what if a hero's duty expert was playing
right now wouldn't that person report
this strange bizarre weirdness alright
pussywillows
Howard Stern called he's pretty sure
you're stealing his bit I'm mostly just
wondering why a family movie from Disney
felt the need to make this joke at all
go away you have to go pretty far out of
your way and money seeking activities to
end up drawing product placement where's
Ralph you should be wrecking the
building okay so now you're telling me
that the innocent apartment dwellers do
know Ralph is supposed to wreck the
building and that's his job
because you can't have these same
characters pissed off when he doesn't do
it Ralph
probably fell asleep in the washroom of
tappers again so when Ralph falls asleep
of tappers does he usually not show up
does this Ralph not showing up in the
game thing happen all the time and if so
why panic at all
Felix speaking Qbert it's the single
biggest view this movie has to offer
Qbert as a game was so infuriating I
can't even enjoy this guy he's climbing
this wall almost like he totally forgot
that if he dies in this game he dies
forever and can't respawn at his own
game again I'm just saying I'd be
nervous about basically everything but
especially free climbing skyscrapers
they only played one game they just open
the arcade before this one game that was
this being arcade already closed grace
under pressure and above all dignity wow
I admit the things this game narrator is
listing make for hilarious juxtaposition
with the actual actions of Ralph they
aren't things a game like this would
consider virtues in its best player
dignity it's a halo ripoff dignity
cartoon character flying in the air and
screaming in slow motion cliche how did
the metal get all the way back here when
Ralph ejected he went backwards but that
means the metal had to come off his neck
and fly an additional thousand feet or
so and magically hook higher up onto
another candy cane tree now it's my let
the record show that in Ralph's defense
vanellope was pretty much a selfish jerk
to him right from the start
yes she does want a gold coin so she
could race but stealing is stealing
cybus would chew up that game faster
than a chicken hawk and a Koopa crippled
roosters force simile aside no you're
wrong it takes ages for the side bugs to
become an actual threat and sugar rush
without a beacon to stop them they'll
consume sugar rush sounds I really began
programming to me it's not her fault
she's programmed with the most tragic
backstory ever if the program is aware
of the fact that it's a program and its
actions are dictated by the code isn't
that the definition of AI is this the
singularity you die outside your game
you don't regenerate you keep telling us
that but we haven't seen it once
segregated seating imagine a world where
you go to a NASCAR race and are forced
to sit with only the people who taste
exactly like you do oh hell
rightful ruler Mac Eric tur somehow went
back in time from the emoji movie and
inspired itself and now it's its own
grandpa casual cannibalism this gold
medal from an entirely different game
works as a gold coin in this game
there's no way that I am racing with a
glitch
that's glitch estates gone you know it's
it's nothing but code now
so now video game code makes a
difference in this world it really
hasn't up until this point I'll lock you
in my function function fun dungeon
you know it's a play on words in a candy
beast race game though wasn't a sweet
space jail pun make more sense like the
pecan can or the jail cell or the
Twinkie clinky holy the bullying is so
over the top in this movie I'm wondering
if Stephen King did an uncredited
rewrite Robin and sugar rush for half a
day and is already speaking and setting
appropriate metaphors and insults the
vibe there Laffy Taffy they're attracted
to whatever makes them laugh no one
knows why they were programmed into this
game but they're perfect decks mocking
us in fact what the hell is all this in
a game where the objective is to race
and the thing that is lost in all this
is what statistically it's these Laffy
Taffy's are i would send this sleeping
guard at the kart bakery but then what
upsets me more is the bakery needs agar
in the first place it's almost like
sugar rush is the most realized video
game in the entire arcade they built the
whole world inside here that has nothing
to do with the game itself so if another
people it's nothing but trash into the
mixing bowl but when Ralph goes to fix
everything the trash magically
disappears except for the TV hello you
can have magically disappearing trash
because it's a video game but you cannot
keep the TV if all the trash is going to
disappear once you get the right
ingredients okay yes this is a terrible
race card but I don't see how that book
we just went through could ever yield a
car more Road worthy than this one diet
cola in a game called sugar rush I
really want to I know I'm a racer I can
feel it in my color she's right of
course and unfortunately because in the
context of what has happened so far to
this point
Ralph is also right the movies diet coke
and mentos gank is super interesting to
me it's both inspired as hell yet
simultaneously dated if anything it's a
lesson to take time to make
certain you want to write off our video
into your hopefully timeless movie they
just left in the game
so the programmers of sugar rush we're
planning some sugar free bonus level and
decided not to include it at the last
minute but just let the code sitting
there by yourself
it's almost garbage around you yeah I
mean everyone here says I'm just a
mistake and that I wasn't even supposed
to exist what do you expect movie has
balls man balls part 1 - punching me
here with Ralph's realization and how
similar his situation is to hers and
then her spelling out how I and probably
most kids felt at some point during
childhood - sins removal for the fields
movie but you're you really don't know
anything do you
glitches can't leave their games whoa no
need for the attitude since you seem to
understand his relative naivete his
ignorance shouldn't bring score also
learning this about glitches makes me
supremely happy knowing swordless link
is forever stuck in n64 ocarina of time
earlier he jumped slightly into the air
and landed and that caused the Mentos to
drop into the diet coke pit but this man
no vibrations at all here I'm just gonna
call this in Konami code pandering you
want to get people unreasonably excited
about something showed knowledge of the
Konami code it's now the secret
handshake for people who played the
original contra and likely have nothing
else in common one of the things it's
not like the others okay now that we've
broken this game down to its very code
how though did this metal get accepted
into the winners Cup
it's Barty Crouch jr. behind this you
know like a verb what vomit in a burp
together no one will be seated during
the Adam Sandler portion of the movie
will be put out of all I forgot all my
subjects will be homeless how would they
even leave the game before the arcade
unplugs the machine
think about this for a second if they
unplug the machine immediately there's
no way for the characters to escape to
the surge protector but if they're left
plugged in long enough to leave before
the unplugging who's to say the machine
wouldn't get plugged back in does the
game now have no characters after that
and what about all those times there's a
power outage or someone unplug the
machine waits for 30 seconds and plugs
it back in where's this movie saying
that being in a machine when it's unplug
would essentially be like death because
then they wouldn't have any of their old
memories when the machine got plugged
back in I don't think you can present
unplugging as a woman outcome situation
can we talk for a second character has
something important to tell another
character but is interrupted for some
stupid that will make the discussion
impossible cliche I'm moving ass in here
but only because somebody is cutting
onions
your mind is probably doing so for good
intentions I'm really not okay about it
but I still recognize the quality
storytelling and emotional beats or the
fact that sometimes dishes need onions
why are you telling me that metal is an
actual physical thing that can actually
physically affect the outside world this
is like when neo stop the sentence with
his mind in the real world only carrots
presented as just a yeah that can happen
kind of thing attendant decide spoopy
yada yada as computer code worse than
the 90s film hackers did because she
crosses the finish line the game will
reset and she won't be a glitch anymore
that seems arbitrary is that how
programs work a glitch crosses the
finish line and the whole game resets
and all that damage King candy did
somehow magically comes undone first
world problems is this society forcing
all these spectators to sleep inside the
grandstands every night god this place
is oh here's the thing movies always do
with races where the hero starts out so
looking far behind that there's
literally no way they could ever catch
up let alone win and yet of course they
always do they cannot hear each other
damn it
even if their engines are made out of
candy they still make noise damn it
that's I bub you brought with you
multiplied of all the things in this
movie that could have been cut it's the
psy bug subplot sure we could a bit of
fun with Felix and Calhoun out of it but
the main story of vanellope trying to
get reinstated into sugar rush is so
much more interesting that could have
simply made this about getting the metal
back and it would've been fine sweet
mother monkey milk it's almost like that
mindless bug new king candy was a bad
guy much in need of a comeuppance
without a beacon there's no way to stop
these monsters because we're all gonna
tell Calhoun what he plans to do here
and maybe they should set a timetable in
case they need to blow the exit Oh
two ladies go I would just like to know
how turbo got eaten by a SCI bug and
that somehow turned him into a mutant
let's not forget the turbo is like 30
year-old programming code and the SCI
bugs are fairly new so how does their
programming mesh together at all
also Agent Smith moth movie just the
fact that he's the villain and he's code
that has grown too strong inside a
computer that
to be enough but there's also the
parallel of inexplicable existence and
powers Agent Smith just refused to die
according to the sequel's so he got to
stay in or come back to the matrix only
now he's got duplication superpowers is
that all about
neo could have a realization about
himself and his abilities and then grow
stronger because he is human but Smith
is just cold and cold that's all I mean
wait movie are we talking about again
I'm bad that's good
look no one loves this movie more than
me no one but this is still a discount
Iron Giant Superman moment here and
denying it only makes you a passionate
liar also it was one thing to have a
sort of reference to the whole Mentos
coke thing but to base your entire
climax around it what does a sudden
grimace sound like because that's the
sound I'm making phallic symbols after
all the destruction and the violence and
death and that race ending abruptly this
should probably not work right code may
say I'm a princess but I know who I
really am Ralph I'm a racer with the
greatest superpower I like the idea that
Penelope isn't the character the game
programmed her to be there's a lot of
nature versus nurture type of arguments
we could get into in that kind of line
but if she was programmed to be the
princess why does the arcade cabinet
show her as a racer someone on the
marketing team disagreed with the
programmers on that did this our bill
say that once vanellope crossed the
finish line everything would be reset
and she'd stop being a glitch how is she
able to still do this glitch if that's
the case we asked them to help us out on
the bonus levels Jesus to the humans who
play these ever wonder why characters
from other video games suddenly show up
in a thirty-year-old machine you know
there's got to be a Billy Mitchell here
who knows fix-it Felix inside and out
and the inclusion of Qbert characters
would be so strange that it would
immediately be newsworthy like aliens
landing on earth newsworthy I'm telling
you guys we haven't been this popular in
years the idea that a thirty-year-old
game would suddenly surge in popularity
just because cuber characters are in it
is goddamn silly
[Music]
no no no God put our mouths on her head
no well what's that new what are you
thick you know what I used to eat for
breakfast cocaine you know what I used
to eat for lunch cocaine
Oh Jeff for dinner was it cocaine
completely illegal in a no way we'll cap
it that was you have pitched in the rock
of virtue a legacy beyond compare that's
Allstate's stand find you and I will
kill you
taffeta darling taffeta sweetheart
winter hingle mccringleberry penn state
university